as our real estate market fluctuates the
owners of 702 cash offer dot com are
here to educate us on the cash home
buying industry and that option for you
all so let's welcome casey and casey
ryan welcome to the show yeah thanks for
having me that's kacie and c-a-s-e-y
right
all right so let's start off with just
saying what 702 cash offer dot com is
yeah we're we're a local home buyer and
uh we've been out here for we're all
born and raised we're a family-owned
company we've been buying homes out here
since uh 2013 um and and in the past few
years we've bought and sold
around 800 homes or so and that's like
flipping right
not always a lot of times you know we we
help people find the best option to sell
whether that's selling um to somebody
who's going to keep it long-term as a
rental or that's to if the because a lot
of the homes that we do buy don't need
anything at all they're in good shape so
we don't those ones we wouldn't
obviously have to flip or do anything so
okay and now what about the market value
are people buying or typically buying at
50 to 70 percent or how does that work i
think
i'm learning right now too yeah i mean
the only time that you somebody would
have to buy at that much of a discount
is if the house is in really rough shape
and now here i mean there is a lot of
older homes and that is a lot of what we
buy but it's usually not that much of a
discount a lot of times we don't buy at
with any discount we'll buy a full
market value if the home's in a newer
home in great shape it's a lot of people
do think a cash buyer buys at a huge
discount and that's not actually the
case okay okay so now and when people
get in contact with you guys um what's
the process like
yeah it's it's very simple so they'll
reach out to us whether they call in or
go to our website and they'll you know
give us their information or just chat
with us live there on the website
they'll give us their name and phone
number and address and we just run
through see you know what some of the
houses in the area are selling for what
they're renting for
and if they could just tell us the
condition it's really quick in five
minutes you could probably have a really
solid offer if the house is in good
shape sometimes we don't even have to
come out and see the house a lot of
times we like to but some people don't
want strangers coming in out of their
home and that's a lot of times why they
don't want to go the traditional route
and put it on the market with an agent
and do all that because they don't feel
comfortable or they don't have the time
to wait so okay okay now what about some
advice for someone who's entering this
space in their lives you know what what
would you tell them
um i i would say i mean you're they're
welcome to call us we work with people
all the time that we don't even end up
buying their home but we just we know
that there's a better option for them or
we're the best option for them but
whether we are we aren't we're going to
point them in the right direction and
they can make the decision themselves
that the internet has all the
information you could ever want yeah but
just reach out to us because there's a
lot of confusion there and people don't
understand the process so we just try to
make it simple and just be transparent
and give them all their options right up
front that's great well thank you for
what you guys do your service and also
your local so that's always a plus
so for more information call
702-745-2274 or just visit 702
cashoffer.com thanks casey